(upbeat music)
- What if we all just
sing at the same time?
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay.
- Oh god.
- I'm living in the 21st century.
- [Everyone] Doing something mean to it.
Doing everything better
than anyone has seen do it.
Screams from the haters,
got a nice ring to it.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together seven Kanye fans.
- I'm a Kanye fan.
- I'm a Kanye fan. 100%
- [Narrator] One is a liar.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they'll split a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
Who is the Odd One Out?
- Should we just all introduce ourselves?
Say our favorite song?
I'm Susie. My favorite
song is Lost in the World.
- My name is Jbruz and my favorite song
is Bittersweet poetry from Graduation.
You see that right there?
- [Susie] Oh okay. Okay.
- My name's Alix. My
favorite song is Amazing.
- My name is Chace and my
favorite song is Bound 2.
- My name is Kerry and my favorite song
is Never Let Me Down.
- My name is Ty and my
favorite song is Famous.
- My name is Jack and my
favorite song is Saint Pablo.
- What's everyone's favorite album though?
- I wear it on my chest.
- Yeah, brand right here.
- My beautiful Dark Twisted Fantasy.
- Yes. Absolutely.
- That's gonna be popular for sure.
- Life of Pablo for me.
- That's good.
- I'll go with you with
that. Life of Pablo.
- When Ty said his favorite
song, Jack was like same,
and I was like that's kinda soft.
Any of you guys seen him in concert?
- [Alix] Unfortunately no.
- Twice.
- Life of Pablo.
- Yeezus.
- Where did you guys see him at?
- Seattle. When he went off on Jay Z.
- Yes. Yes. Yes.
- [Kanye] Jay Z, call me bruh.
You still ain't call me.
- Bro, we were chanting.
We were like going off.
- Oh my gosh.
- My dad was doing security at the time.
So, he was letting me go under the stage.
- Oh, no way.
- That's dope.
- Yeah, it was a twap.
- I saw him at the Meadows Music Festival,
where he left for the
Kim Kardashian scandal.
- I'm sorry this is a family emergency.
I have to stop the show.
- He ran off stage.
- I was like 40 minutes of just
heaven and then it was like,
wow my money is gone.
(laughs) Why did you rob me,
more than you've already robbed me?
- But you know the experience.
Everybody else just watched it on TMZ.
- Yeah it was a part of a
Keeping up with the Kardashians episode.
- [Susie] Yeah.
- It was pretty cool.
(bell ringing)
(upbeat music)
- I voted for Alix just because
she was a little bit more
on the quiet side the first round,
and didn't really get involved,
but I guess neither did I.
So, I can't really say much.
- She was a little bit
too enthusiastic for me.
Which made me suspect that
maybe she has something to hide.
- She stood out because
she didn't stand out.
(buzzer rings)
- Good luck guys.
I only got to say like
four words on camera.
I think I just said
Saint Pablo and my name,
and then I was voted out. (laughs)
- How do you defend him?
Like, you know,
throughout just being a Kanye fan.
Like what...
- That was a good question.
- What is your moment?
I think that everyone thinks that
he means exactly what he says,
but I think that he just has
a really difficult time
articulating himself.
- There would be no Travis Scott.
There would be none of these.
- None of these.
- Influential people without him,
so it's like hard to do away with him,
even when he does problematic things.
- I'm just gonna let him do what he does.
I gonna mind my own business.
I separate him from fashion and music,
to his little politics and stuff.
- He's having like a really human journey
through everything.
- [Ty] Oh yeah.
- Especially since he's
being so vocal about
what he's going through
with being bipolar.
I don't think that's easy.
I do admire him for
trying to articulate it
in the way that he does.
Not in the way that society says,
oh this is how you're suppose to behave.
- What was everyone's pivotal moment
that they knew they were a Kanye West fan?
- I grew up listening to Kanye West.
It was like my mom would put
it on when we clean and stuff.
- What would she put on? Like what?
- Oh, College Dropout. Like Champion.
Come on. We know.
- Yeah, similar experience.
My mom put me on Kanye.
When Tower Records was around.
That's crazy. My family hates this man.
- Do you guys remember Tower Records?
We would go like every other weekend,
and she picked up Late Registration.
I didn't know who he was. I
was a kid. I was really young.
And she puts him on, and
Heard 'Em Say came on,
and I was like this is it.
- (laughs) Uh, her responses,
seemed to frame around just old Kanye,
not so much new Kanye.
- My pivotal moment
that kinda stuck with me
was I was watching MTV music videos,
and just saw this guy
mumbling Through the Wire.
Like you said, we kinda grew up together,
because every time he
would drop something,
you just kind of like know.
We're there with him
throughout all the journey.
- Not to be mean but
she seemed very plain,
very PacSun Kanye fan.
- I didn't really care
about music in general
until senior year of high school.
I just remember The Life of
Pablo was just about to drop
and I was just so curious about it,
because I was reading the Wikipedia page
about how it was like three Pablo's.
It was Escobar.
- Picasso.
- Yeah Picasso.
- And Neruda.
- I don't know. It was just
such a different environment.
- He said like the three Pablo's,
and then he didn't know the third Pablo.
I was like that's really sus.
- Shoot. My cousin put me on to Kanye
when I was like younger and then,
that's when I started to really
develop my love for Kanye.
Not saying that I'm a stan.
- I don't know man. You
have a tattoo of him.
- Haven't you got a tattoo?
- You're pretty dedicated.
- I don't think you just
did that for this video.
- I do. Nah. Nah. Nah. Nah.
I got the angels right here too.
- Can we see the angels? Are
we allowed to see the angels?
- Yeah. Yeah.
I got it right here, and right here.
- Oh wow. Yeah.
- Oh wow.
- That's not from Etsy.
That's not from Etsy.
- She was the least involved
in my personal opinion.
Kerry didn't really give
me like a reassurance
that she was a true Kanye fan.
- Kerry was good.
I think she was playing a tactic
of introducing a question,
but then observing.
(buzzer rings)
- I wasn't super peppy.
I think I was really just
listening and observing,
and maybe they took that as a sign
of some type of concealment.
- [Narrator] If everyone feels confident
that you've already caught the mole
you can end the game now.
But if the majority has
doubt the game will continue.
Please raise your hand
if you wanna continue playing the game.
That's majority.
Starting now for every time
all of you vote out someone
that is not the mole the total
prize money will be reduced.
- Bro what?
- That hurt.
- [Narrator] In this round
you will choose a Kanye song
and finish each other's lyrics one by one.
- Are we allowed to say the
curse words in the song?
- Oh yeah.
- That's what I was like.
- I was gonna do it regardless. (laughs)
- This is a pretty
notable song on the album.
- I know which, yeah.
- All right, so.
We'll just go down the line.
Now if I (beep) this model.
- And she just bleached her (beep).
- And I'ma get bleach on my T-shirt.
- Then I would think I'm an (beep).
- I was fine when I let her.
- We was high in Tribeca.
- She'll get under your
skin if you let her.
- I don't wanna talk about it.
(group laughing)
- That was pretty good.
That was pretty good.
- We rocked that.
- [Susie] That was funny.
- I feel like I'm in Pitch Perfect.
- I met this girl when
I was three years old.
- I know, this is uh.
- And what I loved most she
got so much soul she said.
- Excuse me lil homey.
- I know you don't know me. But okay.
- Ah, okay. Okay.
Honestly, I got really nervous,
and then I just forgot
completely everything.
- I feel like we all know
different or have favorites.
- What about a more miscellaneous
song from that album?
- Made it sound all wack and corny.
- Listed for it blasted boring.
- [Susie And Ty] Sick
addiction, twisted fiction.
- We'll come around
children, zip it, listen.
- Can we get much higher?
- Oh yeah.
- [Alix and Susie] So high.
- We all for real. (laughs)
- Nah, we have a minute and a half or two.
- When a real N word holds you down,
what are you suppose to do?
- Drown.
- This man right here.
I don't know where we're
going from there. (laughs)
- Should we all do Power?
- Alix chose Power for us to
kinda bounce back and forth.
Which that's like a very popular song.
This could be one that kinda
everybody can show up to.
Okay wait. What if we all
just sing at the same time?
- Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
- Okay.
- Oh god.
- I'm living in the 21st century.
- [Everyone] Doing something mean to it.
Doing everything better
than anyone has seen do it.
Screams from the haters,
got a nice ring to it.
- Jbruz. He kinda threw me for a loop.
Just because he couldn't
really come up with anything.
- Maybe you stop being a Kanye fan
after the time you had those tattoos done.
- [Everyone] I guess every
superhero need his theme music.
No one man should have all that power.
The clock's ticking, I
just count the hours.
Stop tripping, I'm tripping off the power.
- I don't think we got any
closer to guessing anyone.
Seemed like a detour on the investigation.
It was like if Scooby-Doo
had a musical episode.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] We have a tie.
It's a five way tie.
- What?
We guessed different people?
- We're like who is it?
We're all Spider-man.
- I've watched this show.
That has never happened.
- Hold on. Hold on.
- [Narrator] One minute
to try to figure out
who the mole is.
- We all love him but
let's be a little critical.
Worst thing he's ever said?
- Slavery was a choice.
- Yeah. 100%.
Another one that he said was,
he went on air for the Red Cross thing
for Hurricane Katrina,
said George Bush hates black people.
- That's pretty fucking bad.
- He doesn't care for black people.
- When he was at the concert
and the guy was in a
wheel chair. That one was.
I can't say the one you
already said 'cause I agree.
- When the red hat thing.
Him running for president
under Republican ban...
We can really like do it, but.
- Yeah.
- Jbruz?
- Uh, I mean,
that house way stuff. (laughs)
I don't know.
I mean he had that interview where
he was like going off on Sway.
- Oh Sway. Sway.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Do it yourself.
- Ha Sway!
- That wasn't that bad though.
- I know. I can't really
think of anything bad though.
- You can't?
(bell ringing)
- I'm like, okay man.
I can't keep defending
you in these streets.
- I thought he was very charismatic
and he came in like so excited.
- Alix was wearing Nike sneakers.
So I was like okay that's pretty sus.
- I love you guys.
- To be honest, I don't really
know why they eliminated me.
- [Narrator] Please raise your hand
if you wanna continue playing the game.
Okay. The game will end now.
If the lights turn green that means
you have voted out the mole and you win.
If the lights turn red that means
the mole is still in the box and you lose.
(suspenseful music)
- Damn.
- Oh no.
- So, are those real tattoos?
I'm surprised.
- I thought we got the mole out.
- [Narrator] Will the fake
Kanye fan please step forward
and reveal yourself in three, two, one.
- Ah.
- That makes sense.
- Every round I voted for
her. Every single round.
- I peeped that though.
I peeped that you were
voting for me. (laughs)
- I was surprised only because
we had all sung together.
I guess at the end of
the day the bag talks,
and she broke my heart.
Bro, it was right in front of us.
The whole time.
- The whole time.
I know.
- Nike's on.
- That should be kind of a dead giveaway
'cause Kanye's so against
Nike and what not.
That's like going into Costco
with a Sam's club card.
- I am no longer a Kanye fan,
but I believe that when you have
a successful platform and influence,
it's your responsibility to
be mindful of your actions
and what it is that you're saying,
so I could no longer be
a fan because of that.
- It makes sense.
You can go from being a Kanye
lover to a hater really quick
because of how volatile
his personality is.
I'm a black creative and
to see a black creative
who deals with mental health issues,
reach this level of
prominence and success,
will keep me routed as a Kanye fan.
And I feel like seeing him in that context
is what a real fan of him is,
in of his legacy and his persona.
- [Narrator] We want to thank
you all for participating
and give you all a gift.
These are Odd One Out bags.
- We're all winners today. (laughs)
- Thank you. I'm gonna sport this.
- [Ty] Drip.
- Good job Alix.
- Thanks guys.
Yeah.
(Upbeat music)
(Alix laughing)